mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bienvenue à radio 100 et beasley
j'entends des gens qui rient sol je vous
préviens tout de suite je vends donc
aucun fruit
pendant ma circonférence je veux pouvoir
entendre le viol d'une mouche
j'aurais cap est de pub et du bas moi je
suis monsieur de tours équipe et hier
nous mandri seule personne mais croûte
dorée qui répète depuis le menu la
beauté site moment sans flou
heureusement fluo fli août et je vous en
prie je vous en prie soyez un petit peu
attentif
certaines personnes ont des problèmes
énormes de chronos ya pion à flines
afflige vous affluent si je vous le dis
si tu venais de sur ce mur
j'aurais québec depuis le début ça
rigole encore vous savez que vous êtes
un super table
j'ai l'impression que je parle dans le
vide à force d'en interrompre et et moi
je vais finir par me rouiller
j'aurais québec depuis levé du bon alors
là moi j'en ai plein le fur j'ai
l'impression que tout ce que je vous ai
ce type ça vous intéresse pas mais faut
mais croûte et ouvrir les orteils
je répète depuis le début du mois d'août
est maintenant celle ci fuit je vous le
dis salsifis maintenant le premier qui
rit sol le fourneau fois c'est la piqûre
j'aurais québec depuis levé dur c'est ça
frier frier on verra bien qui c'est qui
frisera le dernier c'est ça prenait mois
pour un indélébile
je récupère mes deux fils b du bon si
c'est comme ça je répète plus salut